okay
yeah
um cool uh so I'm gonna try to get out
of the way as quickly as possible and
let could you should do most of the
talking here
um but I want to start with an exercise
that we sometimes do in the intro uh
natural language processing class at MIT
uh which is the following you know
imagine that we're sort of sitting here
on Earth and one day we you know
intercept uh some kind of alien
broadcast uh and we you know are able to
at least read off like the following
sequence of discrete characters from
this broadcast
um how might we go about understanding
what it is that is being communicated
here
um and if we have all of this maybe
there's a little bit of structural
analysis we can do on the language but
maybe not all that much uh maybe we're
really lucky and we also have a little
bit of metadata attached to these things
you know sort of images that go along
with these things tentacle ratings maybe
the aliens are browsing alien Amazon and
trying to figure out what's going on
here
um but the question is if we have
especially or or even just this kind of
grounded data how might we actually
understand what the structure is uh in
this communication system and and sort
of fundamentally uh even if we have
relatively Rich data like this
um finding structure in that data is
really hard right we don't even know
what the sort of basic units of this
language might be
um uh how those pieces get put together
to form larger meanings if the meanings
relate in any way to the metadata that
we have access to
um and this problem is especially
difficult if all we have is like a big
fixed data set on which we can't
actually ask questions about new
utterances uh or sort of get labels for
new images
um and it's worth noting right that this
is sort of a fundamentally different uh
language understanding problem that
people face either when they're learning
their first language or when you know
we're sort of going out and trying to
document a language that we don't speak
before uh precisely because we don't
have access to this kind of
interactivity
um so suppose now that you know we're
still hanging out on earth and the
aliens fly by again and they drop off
some kind of black box here uh we don't
know what's inside the black box but
what we do know is that we can put some
strings into the black box in the
Salient language um and we get some
things that come out of a black box that
look a lot like uh the you know the same
distribution of data that we saw in this
original alien signal
um well you know once again we don't
actually understand the structure of
this language uh maybe we don't exactly
understand what the relationship between
this black box is and the actual
language that the aliens speak beyond
the fact that the sort of distribution
of outputs that we get given inputs
looks approximately the same
um maybe this is a multimodal black box
white and you can also put text in and
we can get images out or vice versa
um and what I want to claim is that even
if uh we don't exactly know what the
correspondence is between this black box
and the alien language even if we don't
have the ability to open it up this
gives us a lot more power to understand
what's going going on inside this
language right we can sort of plug in
strings that we've never seen before if
we have very specific hypotheses we want
to test that involve very very simple
sentences maybe simpler than sort of
naturally occur with any frequency in
the alien language we can ask questions
about those sentences specifically
um in this sort of hypothetical scenario
right we don't exactly know what the
correspondence is between this black box
and the real language and so whatever
hypotheses we want to form we're
eventually going to need to validate by
you know trying to talk to the aliens if
the aliens ever come back
um but this is a really useful starting
point so this box yes
maybe it's okay right maybe I put in one
input and I get a distribution of your
outputs okay when you said that
distributes like the data you saw
previously you went for a random input
uh yeah sure in expectation right I mean
so hopefully where it's clear that this
is going right is that uh in a certain
sense right the kinds of language models
that we can train right now behave like
our alien Black Box in this sense right
we can plug some Springs into them we
can get some strings out we can ask
questions about strings that never
appear in the training data uh there
seems to be some kind of systematic
relationship between uh you know the
inputs and the outputs that looks a lot
like the relationship between the
sentences that humans produce uh when
you ask them specific questions or give
them specific prompts uh but in a way
that might actually be a little bit
difficult to to characterize
um right so you know just to put this
another way rather than training uh
these black boxes on alien languages
what we can do is train these black
boxes on the entire internet and then we
can plug strings in English or other
human languages into them uh and get uh
strings in English or other human
languages
um and so what this talk is going to be
about broadly is sort of what we might
do with a black box of this kind and
what kinds of especially scientific
questions both about sort of human
language processing uh and and uh whale
language we can use with kind of
language models broadly understood as a
generic technology for uh for building
models of communication systems uh so
I'm going to talk very briefly about one
little vignette uh from our group that
has nothing at all to do with animal
communication and is actually about sort
of understanding uh brain recordings uh
and then Patricia is going to talk about
uh you know sort of language model black
boxes for understanding how uh whales
interact
we're talking the kind of language
models I'm used to they don't generate
strings they generate probability
distributions and then there's still a
sampling procedure which is highly
highly influential how does that plan
yeah well I mean so there are tricks
that people play with the sampling
procedure to get out uh better text
right but if we sort of forget about
that you know there is a uh
fundamentally what a language model is
is a conditional distribution over next
tokens or a conditional distribution
right so if we want to think about it
that in that in that way right without
any of the extra tricks that people do
for uh
sampling particularly coherent
generation uh just think of these as uh
as conditional distribution
and that's actually going to be
important for something that we're going
to look at
other questions
cool
um so to sort of motivate uh how we're
gonna use the Black Box the alien Black
Box uh to answer questions about the
structure of communication systems right
a sort of Brief Review for for maybe the
non-computer scientists in the audience
of what these language models were
talking about are uh I'll go through
this relatively frequently since I think
some of this has been covered by by
other uh talks in this session uh but
fundamentally what a language model is
uh is a next word prediction model right
just like the one that sort of sits on
your phone and tries to guess what word
is going to come next as you're writing
a text message so we plug some text in
and we get out uh maybe the most
probable next word or in fact maybe a
distribution over words that might come
next tagged with uh the probability that
those words come next and these
probabilities are derived from uh big
Text data sets where in particular
contexts uh you know certain words are
more or less likely to follow
um good uh under the hood these are for
the most part neural Nets using a
specific architecture called the
Transformer which you can think of is
basically every word build some sort of
representation of itself by looking at
all of the words that came before it in
a sentence and eventually we look at the
last representation of the last word uh
and we decode that into a distribution
of exports
um we can build things that look like
language models for uh sequences that
are not corresponding to natural
language strings but data and other
modalities as well we saw this in
Brian's talk yesterday where we could
decode into images or
as well
um so how might you use uh one of these
models right a model that sort of takes
some strings as input and generates some
strings or some images or some audio as
output to understand the structure of a
communication system well one thing that
you might want to do is sort of peer
deep inside this model and actually
understand what computations it is
performing in order to get from its
inputs to its output and learn something
about the structure of the communication
system from the actual internal
structure
yeah so so if we didn't have a black box
what would you do uh uh right uh and and
the best you could hope to do is to sort
of look inside the model look at the
weights and and figure things out um
there have been some successes from
these kinds of approaches maybe the most
sort of prominent one there was a paper
from deepmind a couple of years ago
where they trained a model to solve some
sort of not Theory problem and then
looked at the internal representations
and learn some new invariants from for
for not Theory I think goshper is also
going to be talking about exactly this
kind of approach uh four-wheel
communication uh later today but to
shafi's point uh the question that I
want to ask is what can we do if we
don't want to look at all uh inside the
model
um and one thing that we can do uh is at
least learn a little bit about the kinds
of features of inputs that are actually
relevant uh for controlling certain
pieces of outputs right so here's some
alien string we don't know exactly what
the string means we don't know what the
pieces are we don't know what the alien
language is but we we know that when we
plug it into our model we get a picture
of of a monitor exactly
what happens if we Shuffle some words
around in this input string uh well
maybe we do our shuffling around we
pluggle this into uh into our black box
and the same image pops up and if we do
this systematically right if we can do
this over and over again we can always
Shuffle our words around and find that
that doesn't actually change the the
string that we get out we've learned
something about the structure of this
language right namely that the order of
these tokens probably doesn't actually
matter that much for decoding and
conversely if we Shuffle some words
around and we do get a different picture
out uh then what we've learned is
probably that the word order does matter
and does actually control in some way
um uh the the meaning of this utterance
or at least the sort of relationship
between these input strings and the
outputs that they index and so this
gives us a kind of general purpose
toolkit for asking questions about what
features of a communication system of a
representation system actually matter
and that's something like the following
we'll go out and we'll get a data set of
input output pairs
um we'll train some kind of model or
take our Black Box model that we have
lying around uh and use it to sort of
predict our outputs from our inputs
um and then we'll do the same thing with
a different model where we've
systematically removed some piece of
information from these inputs right
maybe that's by deleting tokens maybe
that's by shuffling them around maybe
that's by doing finer grained
interventions into the system
um we will for reasons that I'm not
going to talk about today probably want
to train a second model on the data
that's been damaged in this way rather
than reusing our first model from
scratch
um and then we'll just compare the
difference in accuracy between these two
models when we evaluate it on our
original unmodified data set uh and the
sort of bigger the difference in
accuracy that you get between these two
models the more consequential uh the
feature that you removed was for the
category of predictions that you care
about making
um there's a nice kind of general
information theoretic framing of all of
this that I'm not going to talk about
today uh that what we're actually
Computing is a quantity called the
usable information that the feature F
contains about this output distribution
uh why all right given whatever
information was left behind uh in the
inputs
um cool and so there's been a bunch of
work mostly in the NLP literature
um using this basic procedure of sort of
taking an input removing some
information from it retraining a model
on it and seeing how much worse that
model gets as a way of understanding uh
sort of both what it is that our models
are actually learning uh in these kinds
of natural language processing tasks uh
and for characterizing other features of
data sets um and so what we're going to
be looking at today is how to sort of go
beyond NLP uh and use this to answer
scientific questions as well
um the first little vignette that I want
to give is actually using this to
understand something about how uh as
we'll get to in the moment either how
language is represented in the brain or
how uh how brain recordings work uh the
leads on this work were Karina and Greta
and this was in conjunction with that
federenkos lab and some other folks at
MIT
um cool so the sort of task that we're
going to be looking at here is the
problem of brain brain decoding uh and
this is something that there's been a
lot of interest in especially in recent
years especially with the sort of
increased success of machine learning
models um and so we have now pretty good
neuralness that can either go from
natural language inputs and try to
predict uh what regions of the brain are
going to be active you know using
various kinds of Imaging Technologies uh
from those natural language inputs or
going in the opposite direction starting
with these kinds of uh
recordings uh and decoding whatever
stimulus a person is listening to or
reading or thinking about from those uh
this works less well but we're at least
like starting to be able to do it um and
so you know this is something that a lot
of people have worked on uh we have
models now that go in both of these
directions and are sort of remarkably uh
successful
um and the question is what is it that's
actually being communicated by these
signals that we are decoding right what
is the information in these strings
that's actually predictive of patterns
of activity uh and you know to the
extent that we can't quite yet go from
patterns of brain activity to like
people's exact uh you know the the
sentences that they were listening to or
whatever what kind of information might
be missing from these things yeah
a sentence sorry the sentences the
sentiment is the same yeah so this
specific example was actually taken uh
from this hang at all paper from Alex's
group uh UT Austin and this is sort of
the state of the art in decoding right
now uh where you can get from uh an
input or you know you show somebody this
sentence uh we just recorded this but we
you know the the neuroscientists just
recorded this using actually fmri and
this is kind of the best output you can
get some of the words of the same
conclusions right
including yeah there's the same great
activity yeah conclusion too that it's
because of how your how good the neural
net is that it is available its ability
to decode backwards it's roughly well
we're not perfect yes
uh probably yeah but hang on so that's
less exciting unfortunately okay but
we'll come back to that
um right so so you know this is sort of
exactly the question uh you know I guess
at a higher level is this an issue with
uh the sort of class of models that
we're using to do this decoding is it
maybe an issue with the Recording
Technology itself that there's
information that's getting left behind
um and you know so we can use exactly
the procedure that we were describing
before to at least start to answer these
kinds of questions right we can take uh
and here we're going to be looking at
encoding models rather than decoding
models
um uh but you know sort of models
trained to go from strings to patterns
of activity and figure out what features
of those strings are actually necessary
to get good alignment uh between our
predictions uh and the Brain all right
and so again right we might want to sort
of remove systematically various kinds
of information from our inputs here and
see what effects those have on outputs
and if we delete these things and they
don't change then they're probably not
actually necessary to do well with this
prediction task if we delete these
things and they do change uh then then
they're important
um so here's an example using a
particular category of these kinds of
feature ablations so here we're starting
with an intact sentence beekeeping
encourages the conservation of local
habitats
um and when you do this you get pretty
good uh productivity of brain activity
like we're seeing over here
um as a sort of control here if we give
a random list of words that's matched
for length to this input uh we don't get
zero productivity so there's a little
bit of signal just in the length of the
sentence that you're giving and nothing
else but obviously a significant
difference between these things
um
and we're now going to start to remove
information in this case about word
order gradually from this so we might
swap uh just two words in the sentence
remember that we're still trying to
predict uh the brain activity uh in
response to the intact sentence uh but
what we feed our our learn model uh is
is one that's been swapped instead uh
and productivity decreases a little bit
but not that much
yeah point one difference on the y-axis
like qualitatively what does that
correspond to so there's
roughly as uh correlation between uh our
predicted sort of pattern of activity
across voxels and like a rank
correlation between our predictive
pattern of activity and voxels and the
actual pattern
of activity boxes it's a little bit more
complicated than that in the sense that
this is has been like a ceiling has been
applied to this for how much you can
sort of potentially recover from the
signal in an absolute sense of it's like
a normalized version of the correlation
but uh but approximately yeah yes so
you're due to the level of words there
are these uh you know these kind of
experiments where you can take a
sentence and you'll change letters
within the same order you still read it
in the same way yeah there'll be some
kind of error correction in the great
Destinies well so yeah as a reminder
like we're only ever trying to predict
people's responses to impact sentences
so we're never going to show people uh
stimulated that have been damaged in any
way you could do that uh there's
actually the M uh using one of the same
data sets that we're doing here uh do
some of those experiments and people not
with sort of word internal shuffling but
we're external shuffling uh actually let
me finish the slide and then I can say
more about that because because it is
um okay uh so maybe the more interesting
thing that happens is if we start to do
more aggressive damage to our input
sentence and continue feeding it to this
model things get worse but they don't
pass a certain point actually get that
much worse
um so uh once you start swapping more
and more words we can be even more
aggressive here right we can reverse the
order of the sentence uh we can
deliberately Shuffle the the words in
the sentence in a way that like
minimizes the mutual information between
words that are adjacent to each other so
that locally the sentence looks kind of
as incoherent as possible
um and really like none of these are
distinguishable from each other um and
so back to Michael's point if you do and
this is not work that I was involved in
but if you do this experiment with
people uh you don't see this trend you
actually see instead like a steady fall
off uh as you uh or rather you see a
significant sorry uh you see a
significant difference between uh this
low PMI condition and all of these other
swaps that are meant to preserve
sorry
doing the experiment with people you
mean people's understanding yeah
yes
you're using a transformer for this uh
so here uh the actual brain decoding
model is
GPS something I don't actually know
exactly right off the top of my head and
then a linear layer on top of the
sentencer okay so then the next question
is were you using absolute or relative
positional encoding for your Transformer
because this could be an effect of the
positional encoding approach to use
um
it's whatever is the default thing that
you could do I can't actually remember
um cool but you know so a takeaway here
is that removing this order from quarter
information doesn't actually
substantially decrease our decoding
interest yeah sorry a small question I
don't think I can understand your answer
so is this like if you show people this
non-intact sentence like their brain
activities
so so here we're just looking at
recordings from intact stimuli uh
there's another paper from apps group
that I can send people that uh that
looks at actually show the people that
but the important thing is that it's not
the same
here yes
um
the same thing
removing
words from sentences rather than
removing ordering information from
sentences and you see a similar kind of
effect where really you can throw away
most things other than like nouns and
verbs and get some other
kind of um and so back to the question
that Shafi was asking before right we've
learned something about the kinds of
features that are actually necessary to
get good uh uh model to brain fit uh and
that in particular those features don't
seem to include ordering information uh
and seem to mostly be about sort of like
word meaning and word similarity uh and
then the big question is why right does
this reflect sort of a limitation of the
information content of the recordings
that we have themselves uh does it
reflect the model that we're using to do
the recording uh or is this just
something about how language is
represented in the particular region of
the brain
um and you know so all like important
questions for future work uh but what
this at least gives us right is a way of
sort of pruning the hypothesis space and
figuring out what kinds of things we
ought to be looking at uh with regard to
word order and and word uh
um and with that I will hand things over
to Patricia who will talk about the
whales
so Communications
error correctly
so do you air correct was so bad
that it is not distinguish between these
type of sentences it's still recover
from the other side yeah well with with
the same degree of accuracy right which
is clear like obviously word order
matters for people who are doing
language understanding so somewhere at
some level of representation like the
order of information is getting
processed in your mind or you could put
a neural net again to do whatever
come on
uh sorry I'm not sure so I'm thinking
about this as an apparati Square
so you start with one sentence something
happens in the middle of this obviously
that's not going to be the sort of thing
that
but we're saying change the orders you
erase words I don't know what really
remains of trouble this but somehow
you're able at the end to recover
something that has a similar sentiment
so
um using the neural Nets in the middle
the way that you're this is recovered
oh right so so something that a separate
thing that you can do sort of
independent of any of the spring stuff
and actually what we were doing that
he's asking this question just about
language itself right how many bits are
in order that you need to do next steps
prediction how many bits are in word
identity for words of various kinds uh
yeah and you know importantly like
especially in the long-range context
order information really doesn't matter
all that much uh in general although
this varies from language the language
people are pretty good at uh recovering
the meanings of sentences and sort of
descrambling words in sentences that
have been scrambled obviously you're
going to miss out on uh
distinctions that matter in rare cases
right like if I give you man bites dog
uh and I don't tell you uh whether those
words run right order or not you're
going to conclude that the sentence was
probably done bites man but that means
that I've never been going to be able to
actually communicate the rare man bites
dog of them
um uh right but you can use in a stool
kit also just ask questions about uh
about language itself and not and so
representation
cool all right
um okay so now we're going to be looking
at how by some of these things be
applied oh maybe the same kind of tests
we applied to understand
and uh before we get into how are we
going to do it let me introduce this
from wave which is the way we're
studying
um to some whales are the largest are
animals with the largest brains to have
ever existed on the planet and they've
had it for 16 million years longer than
us and we live in these really complex
matriarchal societies with
multi-generational bonds
the members of the family they dive
together they coordinate babysitting
each other's young ones and they also
like can coordinate incomplete Darkness
and while they coordinate in complete
darkness they exchange long sequences of
sounds with one another
while many details about this film with
communication remains to be discovered
they're fruitful points of comparison
between sperm whales and aspects of like
a well-studied communication system such
as the human communication system
and inspired by the study by hawkett in
1960 the stable highlights how
different aspects of human language
might have possible analogues in other
communication systems like really
primitive animals to fairly complex
animals and how each of these uh
different features of language might
contribute to the animal's ability to in
turn perform different kinds of
behaviors
today we're going to be looking at where
this sperm whale communication really
lie in this hierarchy is it exhibit a
sweet structure does it have
hierarchical syntax long-range
dependencies is it productive
or useful with uh exhibit any kind of
displacement so you're not going to be
looking at all of these questions today
but what we'd probably focus on a few
okay so sperm wheel sounds sound
something like this
so if clicks were to be represented by
vertical dashes they would look
something like this and these clicks are
not randomly distributed in their calls
but they have more structure and they
back into these groups there are
oftentimes called coders
okay so the communication system of
sperm leads is believed to be made up of
distinct sequences of clicks called
coders and past researchers identified a
set of discrete coder types and 21 the
street coded types in the Caribbean to
be precise
a subset of these coder types have been
found to encode information about the
speaker's identity the Clan's identity
but almost everything else about the
spermill communication system including
questions of about structure and
information carrying capacity remained
unknown
so the first thing we did was develop a
bunch of visualization tools to better
understand
how might they even go about looking at
these clicks
right so instead of plotting these
clicks horizontally like this
you're going to project them along the
y-axis such at every Point represent
like the X position represents the time
the click occurred at from the beginning
of the file and the Y position
represents the time at which the click
occurred from the first click in the
coder
if you do this and along the along with
doing this we're also going to scale up
the y-axis so we can really look at the
structure
um the structure of Dakota
I'm doing this for all the clicks it's
going to look something like
this what I'm going to be saying now is
good of Sound by arbitrary but yeah
please bear with me
so now let's it is another speaker we're
going to do the same and they're going
to represent their clicks with a
different color
and following that just so we can keep
track of how the code has evolve they're
going to connect uh clicks across coders
made by the same whale with lines
we call this an exchange port
so now if you look at 30 minutes of
exchange between multiple Wheels it
starts to look something like this
and the exchange plot already highlights
so much more structure and variability
in the course of the sperm waves that
the clicks represented as dashes fail to
show
we're going to zoom into one of these
plots
How Wheels represent Wheels produce
coders with different tempos like with
analogy there's a musical terminology
they have different kinds of rhythms
there's also these randomly scattered
extra clicks
and they also gradually vary the total
duration of their overall encodiles
so now going back to how Jacob analyzed
uh brain recordings now we want to
really understand what aspects or what
what features of this communication
system might actually be communicative
and possibly what uh function might they
serve but we are not going to be looking
at the second one we only see just a
little bit
yeah
I think so
okay so now we're going to be looking at
instead of brain decoding we're going to
start looking at how can we decode the
communication system of ways
where we make perturbations to the input
and try to see how that might affect uh
What uh the output might look like right
and in our case we're going to be
looking at uh we'll first
train a model or overweight
vocalizations similar to a language
model reveal condition on both what were
the calls that the whales made
previously along with the identity of
the waves if you have information about
the speaker identity and what they said
and when they said so and for following
that we'll predict what was what's going
to be said who's going to say it and
when might they say it
the teachers we're going to be looking
that we test that we're going to be
looking at today include uh information
about long-range contacts like how long
of how far behind in their conversation
context do Wales really like uh depend
on to produce the next sound that
they're going to produce and there are
also other like specific features such
as uh like what if you interchange the
word order or like remove certain
aspects of the features that I talked
about in some of the slides before how
does that affect the quality of
predictions
on the left side is a plot showing how
the ability of the modern to predict the
next Coda or who's the speaker and so on
uh changes with increase in context
like most animals are believed to have a
10 only to Shorter con like shorter
times in their in their history at prop
like do not even attend to conversations
maybe really long time ago but this
shows that uh
to some degree increasing the context
window to maybe five previous calls lets
the model predict what's going to happen
next better
another thing that you could study is
really what is the complexity of the
model that might fit this data
distribution the best right and to do
that we train a few different types of
models uh starting with the engram model
then the then an RNN model and LS
Network model and an LST model and we
see that while an engram model uh can
fit the data really well training a more
complex model like allows uh
predicting some of these longer range
dependencies better
another interesting thing is that if we
drop out certain features of the wheels
uh calls it ends up being the case that
the such as the extra click it ends up
being the case that you the the ability
of the model to predict changes in
coercing Behavior decreases
accuracy Behavior here I mean the next
speaker might drop a turn join or turn
or might end the conversation so in some
sense aspects of uh their calls tied to
decisions that they're making they're
also in the context of their
communication
if you drop out uh like
information of of the
so I think the dollars is 50 50. so if I
have if this is what so for example with
the extra click without the extra click
oh yeah
when you manipulate like these things
that started as audio do you like
discretize them and then feed in
discretized stuff
and every corner is represented as a
vector of rcis
so
what's Dakota
yes uh so there yeah so I guess shake it
out there's a question everywhere okay
so I guess the way you decide is that uh
so typically within one second if
there's no other click then all the
clicks that occurred before then and
were made by the same wheel or group
plus one coder
on average like it's the same way it
produces another coder it's directly
after four seconds of producing Uber
specifically referring to this idea of
moving words around you mean taking the
entire Coda and moving it yeah
yeah and you know certainly one could uh
be in this same Paradigm specifically
like because they're only in a relative
uh relationship
in separate groups and separate groups
in seti are looking at parts of within
Dakota or what we'd be traditionally
calling a quota and whether or not you
recover the same information by having
pieces of it being gone
so far the definition of Coda has been
propelled
so you said that there are 20
.3 Dakota types so
um
which three of the same quotas meant
something within I mean maybe they're
counting schools of fish
like an individual versus
it so when you do you count how many are
in a series
right yeah great question so I got this
talking about here
that condition on the effective
representation of the photo but the
context itself like if there was
information you can tell me such photos
of Might result in being able to predict
what's happening next and maybe some
internal features
exactly like the one
too okay so maybe three of my ignorance
of how you're training the model so it
looks like unsupervising like the you
know the computer find patterns when
it's out right but
um are you giving reasons
I don't know what the right
into parts of engaging the system
directions
yeah that's a great question so we're
training these models identical to how
Jacob describe like language models are
trained right and you could think of it
as self-supervised like basically give
it a sentence you can take different
pieces of the sentence
you can take different chunks of these
conversations
yeah
sorry just to add on to that so like in
the same way
we can find the models sort of
internally recover uh information about
the hierarchical structure of natural
language institution actually has some
unrelated work on doing that in models
of natural language uh you could imagine
that if clusters are relevant or numbers
are relevant or whatever else uh then
that'll eventually get picked up
thank you
okay
well the reason why you did that was
supposed to one well your garden says
yeah that's a great question so like I
think both of those quests like I think
both the questions are important I mean
we have models that are just a good way
of course and I think they tell you
different ways right like if I say my
name is and you know I say my name but
like in a dialogue it's possible like uh
as you might have the two aspects one a
dialogue will tell you about not just
how single Seekers and like sentences
are produced but it'll also tell you
about other aspects of discourse like
when our tones changing what kinds of
responses uh are likely to be made after
someone says a particular thing and so
on right so that's one but another
interesting thing is unlike how humans
like we wish kind of mostly wait for
another person to finish speaking before
we speak who is do not it's not the case
exactly in ways again not interrupting
over one another so the notion of a
sentence or a full like a complete
sentence is not very clear in the case
always but yes I think both of these
questions that can help you also
right
so the other thing we saw was so earlier
we were just talking about being able to
predict the next call but in fact you
could condition on different amounts of
uh conversational context and predict
aspects of behaviors of these waves such
as when the whale might die given a
conversation
and what we see is oh like while we
might not be able to see exactly what
the way it's saying before they die
conditioning on
okay enough enough of a context window
you can kind of also
predict when the whale might die or so
you're trying to be intentionally wait
because our some of these papers under
review and we cannot talk about them
all right so I guess what we saw with
calls contain some information about the
context and future behavior and while
these models might not be perfect you
can still do these kind of uh you can
kind of do these ablations to check how
changing specific features of the input
affect your output and might uh tell you
something about the original data
distribution
and in this case I think this tool is
specially useful because ultimately we
do not have a speaker in both the
languages and this is kind of our only
way to comment about the data
distribution
designing specific features
so in conclusion
yeah so Black Box Hero models make it
possible to quantify what parts and what
features of a signal might carry
information and the way to do that is by
either dropping them out modifying them
and looking at how it changes how the
model responds to some of these changes
so this gives us a very powerful jumping
off point for exploratory data analysis
and hypothesis or formulation
we've also used the two identify
information absent from brain recordings
and ones that are present and spawn with
communication systems
this will probably make sense only to
the people who are excited so the dive
information is the PHR or perh Matlab
files yeah all right thank you
thank you
I just want to make sure I'm I'm getting
like that high level here so
um I train a model on on transcribed
sequences of codex
um the context needs to be now I wasn't
sure what five it said 5K is that 5 000
prior coded I think the K was just
available representing the oh okay so so
five prior codas yeah so I have five
prior codas I trained a GPT model that's
my attention window and then I look at
predicting the next out of a set of 21
possible codas
26.
okay and then I predict which you know
it's important to say as Shane was
alluding to that like the precise number
categorization scheme is uh a little up
in the air but uh but one thing you can
actually do with this toolkit is exactly
ask questions about you know if I have
like two different theories about what
the actual code inventory is uh I can
sort of adjudicate between them based on
whether one or the other contains enough
information to
great future vocalizations okay and I
guess the plots here were with maybe 21
prototypes but we also have experiments
where we change this like now we've got
a types represent the code AS
differently including the icr vectors
itself and go and try to predict the
vectors by themselves and then look at
uh like maybe what representation system
s and like least drop in information
yeah okay uh so so I guess my last
question here is and this is kind of
like a meta Rhythm question so so I get
that you identify codas by number and
Rhythm of the clicks within the group is
that right
yeah
so the types are decided by the internal
spacing of the chicks which like if you
were to let's say you know we make I
think this is Shane's example but like
if you do
right where's the studio or slower
I have the same Rhythm so Rhythm uh
typically is when you normalize the
coders by the total duration you can
talk about things with the clicks
independent of the tempo the decoder
types are decided uh like jointly over
both of these features okay so both
Tempo and and rhythmic pattern yes
within a code and so I'm just wondering
uh have you all looked at rhythmic
pattern between codas or do you turn
them into just a sequence
pattern
pattern cross different photos of this
of any kind of
arrangement of these coders itself I
guess I was just wondering if there were
patterns in the spacings like so now
I've got my 21 codas yes and I can have
a larger rhythmic pattern over the
spacing of the codas and I was wondering
if this is something you guys have
encoded or are looking at yeah that's a
great question so uh like in this
experiment like so the information that
we condition on is the coda type the
time at which the coder was made right
and who the speaker was right so the
time if you have both the coded type and
the time at which the coder was made
just like oh the other question if there
is
a rhythmic pattern across different
coders that might get picked up on but I
don't know if the other if interpreting
your question differently
a whale typically makes the next coder
four seconds apart back on average with
just some variants so there was we do
not really pick up on any such structure
across coders but um yeah
[Music]
can you say something about the the size
of your data set and
as far as I know it's not huge right and
putting a lot more data and how you
think that this will improve the
accuracy at the moment yeah yeah that's
a great question so yeah I think we'll
talk about this a little bit yesterday
so the the data set we're looking at
currently is the dominicus for my
project data set that Shane and has been
collected and they're looking
specifically at the ec1 clan which is a
particular plan so whales in the
Caribbean and the total number of coders
is about
3840 right so that's not many coders but
while we cannot train really big models
on such a small data set because they're
overfit really quickly we trained really
small models and while these models are
limited in terms of their expressivity
is compatible with larger models you can
still ask these questions with from one
of those systems better than random
right so yeah and I and to the second
part of your question with more data we
can train more expressive models right
and they're like both the quality of
predictions that the model makes will
improve but you can still ask the same
questions and
yeah
so with more data the quality of the
modern resolution like you're basically
it's your lower predictional If there
really are
features that the smaller models are not
picking up
I had a quick question are we done oh hi
thanks for a great talk for so
um so I just want to maybe I missed
something so maybe I can ask you also uh
Shane how so how many codas you have how
many coders and are they each code is
there Coda per animal that you've
identified
or that
so so uh right now in any of this
analysis we're not using code for animal
right because it's just sequences made
by different animals and the identities
are always oh like you know quoted as
integers also the first Speaker second
speaker third speaker rather than uh
whale named X whale and Y so all this
analysis does not really rely on
specific identities with individuals but
yes there is that breakdown of which uh
coders were made by which he goes at
least for the waves that were tagged ah
okay thank you I just wanted to clarify
that wasn't sure that like this uses the
the most hand annotated subset so like
these four thousand is the part where
we've had grad students doing the hand
annotation for a number of years and
then there's another larger data set
where you know we're making big advances
on like automating The annotation which
comes into sort of what France was
talking about yesterday about applying
new methods to augment the data set
because you know for every minute it
takes eight to 12 minutes to have
someone sit there I'm sure all your
computer science are familiar with that
kind of thing
um but yes like
prior to setting and reinforced in seti
you know there are quotas where we can
recognize different levels of social
structure but that's independent from
from the sequencing and the work that
Patricia's presenting thank you for
clarifying thanks
[Music]
yeah
we need two microphones I think
okay thank you I have a question for
Jacob about the idea of
altering the input to measure what
changes in the output and maybe
something I missed before but these
models this black boxes usually are
non-deterministic so
you have diffusion you have different
seats also language models you do uh
you you sample from a probability
distribution so how can you be sure that
the alteration is
from the inputs and not from the
non-deterministic nature of the model
yeah so I guess
the case that a language model is
non-deterministic Right a language model
represents a conditional probability
distribution you can choose to sample
from that distribution or you can just
ask what the probability is of some
fixed Target string uh given it's a
fixed input string and that probability
is going to be the same every time you
query the model and so that's all we're
doing here right that sort of in
practice what we're looking at is uh
like the log of the conditional
probability of some ground truth Target
sequence that came next given a version
of the input from which information is
removed
oh
sorry
thanks for really great talk both of you
um I I had a question for Patricia
um I was wondering so I guess first I
was wondering with these models are you
just trying to predict the next coda in
a sequence or are you also trying to
predict the um the context like the
behavior of the whales as a function of
the the sequence of codas yes okay so
that's a great question so
um we're doing both and in fact like
this experiment like this one was trying
to predict the behavior right and uh one
other thing which I did not mention is
that we're not just predicting the next
coder but we're trying to predict the
next few coders because sometimes the
next coder itself sees very little
change
like and on average of the model this
fits to the original data distribution
or just predict the exact same coder but
uh some of these models also predict
longer uh like sequence lens so you can
actually see them
so the model is being
receives a penalty if it does not
predict in the next encoders correctly
and so on but yes both both when both
the types of the code uh the types of
decoders when the coders are made
because that is also an important
feature in these uh
uh in this Instagram with this course
where you know we can interrupt each
other and so on
when there might be a change in speaker
and what as and like aspects of behavior
that we know about
so I had a follow-up question to that
this is more speculative but I was kind
of wondering do you have any idea
um if it would be possible to apply this
type of technique to a system where you
don't necessarily know what the units
are so you have like discrete codas that
you can identify and tokenize but what
if you had a system where you don't know
what the units are you don't know how
many units there are you don't even know
if there are discrete units is there
some way that you can kind of apply this
process of ablation to to test for the
possibility that there are units and
then identify them yeah no that's a
really nice question so
Dr Brian stock from yesterday like where
instead of trading on known tokens or
like or guests of possible tokens you
can train on the audio file itself right
and the other thing you could do is to
that is if you want to work directly
from raw data right but another thing
that you could alternatively test which
I guess connects back to one of the
questions somebody else asked is if you
have a guess over a possible sets of
tokens right and then you could train
different models over all possible sets
of tokens right and you could see which
uh tokenization scheme results in like
loss and predictability over fixed
representation of the output right and
that might tell you which tokenization
scheme might even be better right like
if I represent all coders with just a
single token right versus I represent
let's say five tokens which might be
more informative
than really conditioning on just a fixed
token doesn't tell you too much about
what might happen next right but if you
were to represent them by five different
tokens you have more information to
conditions
as well so you could use these methods
to also decide on what might the right
tokenization scheme
thank you yeah
[Music]
yeah um is what just to follow to what
you said um your question so is that
would that be accurate to describe it as
injecting simulated codas or is that
kind of a different technique
inject things back so I don't think I
understand what it is like you make up
Lakota and then you inject it into the
you simulate codas and then you eject
them into the model and then you apply
that trained model to real signals like
do you use do you harness simulations in
order to improve your actual study of
yeah I guess you could say that I'm I'm
not sure I understand uh yeah I mean
we're not really really doing that here
you know and sort of
I guess one way of thinking about that
that you can do right so right now when
we talk about removing information from
these inputs it's mostly like literally
we're just either hiding okay some piece
of information about the input Coda or
truncating the input so hiding
information about the past uh another
way that you could accomplish the same
goal that would sort of have the same
effect of removing information would be
to train this model not on uh
data sets from which code has just been
removed or code of features have been
removed but instead for into which noise
has been injected right right things
around uh randomly injecting extra space
in between Netflix and Dakota or
whatever and I think you expect those
kinds of interventions to have the same
effect as what we're doing here but
that's not explosive okay got it that's
super helpful okay my original question
was um I learned from David I think that
these clicks are one of four kind of
vocalizations in sperm whale's
repertoire is that right am I getting
that number right so this might be like
future testing but are you thinking
about analyzing the different kinds of
vocalizations together with the click so
like click click me like click click B
and then I like dive to like go get fish
um are you looking at the or I imagine
in this good spec to Diana's question
that like
um the kinds of clicks that a mother
sends her calf are really different than
the like bonded pair so I know that you
haven't gotten so far as identifying the
whales but like I'm just really curious
to know how you're going to integrate
this data into the future of um of
understanding social relationships and
predicting future Behavior through
vocalizations that um are beyond the
clicks yeah
so I guess oh so one thing as Jane
mentioned the the current studies are on
this heavily annotated data set where
only the coders are annotated but yes in
principle you could like
either a train on the complete audio if
you have enough data right or like if
you have a guess of how some of these
Tech ones you know what these sounds are
and have the annotated condition on also
uh those sounds represented as some
tokens
end of like how so we've asked questions
mostly about diet Behavior Uh and not
that much about social relations but uh
yes in principle you could use this very
same model to predict other things such
as social relations
I would also just add that codas are
like a significant majority of
utterances so the the trumpets and like
these Coda creeks and so on are rare
occurrences in the vast majority of
conversations when they get hypersocial
and the whole family comes together and
there's seven or eight animals and they
go crazy for 45 minutes then it then it
approaches things that you might compare
to like the bottomless Dolphins where
there's lots of sounds going on all at
the same time
um but the the code is our makeup a huge
proportion of the sounds they make and
they're highly temporally structured so
like if and I'm happy to we're all happy
to show and we can all listen to CODIS
that it the reason that we came up with
this this being a discrete unit is that
it's four seconds apart from the thing
that it previously said meaning that
that specific individual so that's where
the the thing began it's it's a lot less
complicated than signature oh she's gone
then then signature whistles where the
question became well where does the
whistle start and end this has an at
least as an outside Observer an obvious
place to start and so far all of the
distance within Coda or between Coda
sort of supports that as an idea so but
you're right there's lots of complexity
to add and that's where seti's spending
a lot of time on automatic detection of
all of these different types to do The
annotation rather than having hordes of
graduate students spend a huge amount of
time
yeah great talk thank you um did uh did
you guys mention a tool kit or were
there two tool kits did somebody mention
a toolkit no I thought I thought I heard
the word I mean in in the like abstract
sense but not in the sense okay
[Music]
you know the method of blocking out
stuff you know
but the part about the brain where you
had like the sentences to images and
then images to sentences where these
sentences had similar art in terms of
sentiment and so forth
you're imagining something like that
down the line because I can't see where
right now it's too far right to do these
kind of fancy things
I mean sorry you mean I'm like doing
fmris towards no not if I'm rise forget
about that I wasn't thinking either I
mean any kind of backwards and forwards
so you're going forward all the time but
I'm curious what would be the
uh kind of backward analog you know yeah
I mean
I guess one sort of meaningful
distinction between the two houses that
when we're talking about this uh sort of
brain encoding uh fundamentally there's
two modalities right the sort of y's are
images and the X's are sentences uh in
the experience that Patricia was talking
about there's only one modality we're
trying to well I guess that's not
entirely true right there's the you know
sort of trying to predict future
vocalizations for present vocalizations
and then all the other social behavioral
whatever context uh and certainly then
you could imagine training a model that
goes in the opposite direction like
going from trying to predict
given that I'm in state x what are the
kinds of localizations I'd like to save
and also the amount of data you have
right now you cannot really get a
generative model can you I mean it's a
it's a general it is a generative model
not good to score things
yeah I mean I think it's you know
fundamentally it's kind of hard for us
to assess
how good the generative model is because
you can't you know look at the output
and say oh that seems grammatical uh
right so I have no playback possibility
yet or a reaction yeah right so I mean
the thing that one could do would be a
playback experiment right take this
language model
play uh one side of uh of a dialogue and
you know right now I think we don't you
know that's like you can do that and
that's an experiment that you could run
it's not clear what the actual
scientific question is there unless
there is a specific I certainly would
have the forward and backwards thing
yeah no but even then you know I think
where where we imagine this being most
useful is right we
say at some future point we identify
some feature that we think means okay
the specific behavior needs to come next
or I'm talking about this well it's not
present right here or whatever uh then
the playback experiment that you do is
to uh have one version of this model
that can produce the message that you
think is Meaningful and one version of
the model that cannot produce the
message that you think is Meaningful in
comparative of behaviors that result
from whales having conversations with
those two different models uh and I
think we're like
not even at the point of having
identified anything that concrete but
but that's what that looks like and you
know then it's an interesting separate
question of whether like to what extent
you need conversation and need the
ability to like respond in real time uh
and you know in the limit of uh
having unlimited data
you could drain this model you could put
it in the water with the whales you know
suppose we deal with all kinds of other
issues associated with them actually
getting you know believing that this uh
recording system that we've stuck in the
water water is is actually whale that
they can talk to you know that
conversation will then happen it'll have
the same distribution as the
conversations of the whales uh
themselves say that doesn't necessarily
imply that we understand it no of course
um
one last question so you did
distinguish between the kind of
conversations that are happening before
you dive before you go up whatever there
were a few
the distinguishing is very clear it's
very separate type of uh Dakotas or is
it just a distributionally there's some
shift so that that's the thing that
we're still looking into right now you
know
there's being able to predict and then
there's figuring out what features are
are actually the predictive future
and the way to do that would again be
just to modify like like in a controlled
way the different features right like
the Rhythm Tempo and so on
and uh but also to answer that question
there are like differences across the
different contexts that are visually
clear and also
there are like certain features that
allow making the prediction better yeah
excellent well thank you um really
exciting morning thanks to our morning
speakers uh Roberto Jacob producer um
we'll take 30 minutes and uh and and
reconvene